[Music]
the countdown to the royal wedding is on
guys hey I'm Danny direct oh this is so
fishy Lacey guys were just a couple of
days we're in matter of days away from
Prince Harry Oh Meghan markle's big big
day which is why the daily Denny will be
live every day this week telling you
guys everything you need to know about
this big global event okay I mean it's a
big deal it's a huge deal I'm single as
they come but Sophie got married almost
two years ago although two years in July
in July she knows what it's like to plan
a big party like this maybe not like the
Royal yeah what were you doing like were
you feeling and what was going on the
week leading up to your big day so I
also had kind of a destination wedding
it was in Napa California so a lot of
people coming in from the East Coast and
stuff not quite you know London or
anything like that but I was dealing
with a lot of people coming in and and
and getting ready and doing all of that
kinda stuff and it's kind of stressful
time yeah but honestly at that point
when you just have a week left for me I
felt like I've done everything that I
can do at this point so all that's left
to do is have fun and I was really
excited I was just ready to see
everybody I hope Meghan and Harry are
having fun with at this point of the
wedding planning you know Amy because
this is a huge also they have a lot of
help you know they're all so I hope they
get to enjoy it but I can't imagine
throwing an event on this scale I mean
literally the whole world is watching
these guys of course Harry found himself
a nice American girl so all of us here
states are equally as excited you know
and you know as much as they are these
huge figures to us and this is a wedding
on an enormous scale to them though you
have to remember their friends and
family are coming in they're just Megan
and Harry you know so they're probably
texting them being like hey right you're
right their friends are gonna be there
too and it's also not a state affair
like Prince William and Kate's wedding
or so it's a little more intimate as we
reported to you guys last week so it'll
be a good time yeah are you guys as
excited as we are let us know in the
comments section while we break
everything down but like I mentioned
this really is a global event so you can
only imagine what it's like down there
in the UK right now I can't even imagine
on the scene right now I got to be
insane
well lucky for Sophia lucky for you guys
we actually have our girl lauren zima on
the ground and london she actually is
coming to us now with all the t about
what's going on down there in the UK
leading up to the big day hey Lauren
thanks Denny we are in London where the
red double-decker buses black taxi cabs
and royal wedding fever are all abundant
we spent our day getting to know this
amazing city with a few little missteps
along the way let's take a look
[Music]
hi guys i'm lauren zima we are here at
Hyde Park in London we have made it to
cover the royal wedding and I'm going to
ask a few people what we absolutely have
to do over here oh where are you from
they're from Spain okay we tried thank
you
everyone's a tourist here come more
people with suitcases great do you live
around here well no what are three
things that we have to do while in
London in London go to Buckingham Palace
go to the houses of parliament see Big
Ben and stuff like that and go to some
Paul's Cathedral High Park over there no
no this is Green Park
Wow screwed that up thank you we weren't
even in the right Park crap hi guys i'm
lauren zima reporting to you from not
hyde park so we're going to go find it
apparently it's over there
all right we've gone from a mistake to a
full emotional meltdown we are on Diana
Princess of Wales's memorial walk so now
I feel great about this complete
directional mishap I want to learn about
England so maybe we just casually jump
into this tour that we didn't pay for
the mic is too conspicuous
I'm in heels so this man is going to
help us what was your name sir
Alex Alex taking us to Hyde Park thank
you Alex okay great thanks Alex
so Alex see you have to abide by the
regular rules of traffic okay he does oh
here we go
my pants are loving this put a wide-leg
trouser is not ideal for bike travel so
Alex what's to the right here is that a
wellington arch to the right wonderful
we're seeing London from Alex's bike
that's it we made it well thank you for
the trip can you what who's your
favorite royal prince albert it sort of
throwback okay thank you thanks Alex
we made it
[Music]
when in the Rose Garden literally stop
and smell the roses here in Hyde Park
the Queen may have her throne but you
can have a bench and look who caught up
with us the tour bet they're wondering
how we got ahead of that
wondering how Ichi yes it is us we're
back while you were learning we were
riding are you wondering how we got over
here
we took a bike mm-hmm much quicker than
walking Oh how's your tour going what
have you learned the most important
thing history what's your favorite thing
you learned all the history of these
places
[Music]
Hyde Park is beautiful the sun is
shining but we've got to check out
another quintessential area of London
Piccadilly Circus we've heard that there
are tons of Prince Harry and Megan
Markel things to see there and maybe
even buy and one thing you must do in
London guys hail a black taxi cab
or a bus we're getting in one an actual
black
do people here have the sense that the
royal family is moving forward I think
so with the Prince Harry definitely bit
bit bit more than his brothers older
brothers a bit more traditional but I
think carries a bit more down to earth
would you like a yeah okay seems a nice
guy he'll they've met him but I'll take
you for a pint if you bump into him
while I'm down here that's just a little
taste of London we have so many amazing
interviews for you guys so make sure to
check it all out as the week ahead of
the Royal Wedding continues now I gotta
go try to catch this bus Denny get back
to you not gonna wait for me haha Thank
You Lauren clearly she's having zero fun
out there
it doesn't Yeah right
yeah it's the beginning of the week you
guys who knows what's gonna be like on
Friday calm before the storm you're
gonna say I bet well just wait till
Saturday and of course we're gonna bring
you all the coverage we will show you
exactly what it's like down on the Seas
Lauren is actually gonna give us a
little taste of what's going on in the
UK and in London and all the excitement
around the royal wedding all week so you
look forward to that guys that's gonna
be real good I can't wait to see what
she's alright I thought she'd be the one
that's most likely to be late to her own
wedding yeah for sure she's married
though I think she made it yeah she made
it so Lauren's not the only one in
London we actually spotted the Spice
Girls spice corner spotted in London
further igniting the speculation that
they are performing at the royal wedding
what do you know which let's also say
it's not that weird for the Spice Girls
- that's true that is very true however
we are all very excited because there
has been so much buzz about whether the
Spice Girls were going to be at the
wedding whether they're gonna be
performing at the wedding but a lot of
rumors going around here's what we know
Mel B Geri Halliwell and Emma Bunton
were all spotted meeting up together at
a swanky London hotel catching up having
a little girl time so et has learned
exclusively that the Spice Girls have
been invited to the wedding all of them
and that they will be attending now as
to whether they'll be performing that's
up in the air there's no word on whether
they're gonna be performing or anything
like that
that said it's Harry and Megan we're
hearing that this is going to be kind of
a rowdy after-party
you never
what could happen if all of them are
there they might hop on a microphone you
never know listen if I had all five
Spice Girls in the same room no matter
what the event was I would grab a mic
real quick I'd be like hey guys come on
little little girl power little wannabe
spice up our lives girls let's hear it
at least a lot I really want I you know
we've talked to Mel B a couple of times
now and she is only played coy about
whether or not they're gonna be
performing I mean we'll see when the day
comes but maybe she doesn't know right I
feel like that is something that could
come together at the last minute you
know I mean obviously they want to
rehearse and all that I don't think it's
that serious I feel like a guest might
right approach them and be like you guys
gotta get them you know drinks you're
right cause like we mentioned it's not
gonna be a state official event right
you know so it is gonna be a little more
laid-back for lack of a better word
obviously there's a grand scale of
things there and the grandeur of the
Royal Wedding of a royal family of
course but it will be a little more
intimate so you're right it might be one
of those things where just passing the
mic and there are two sides to this
wedding - I know that's been reported a
lot there's gonna be the big more formal
affair with a lot more guests and then
there is an intimate after-party I
believe about 200 people on that guess
what guest list I think that's gonna be
the more wild one and we were talking
about like man we would love to be a fly
on the wall at that at that reception
I'm dying to know how many details do
end up coming out like how closely
guarded that special reception is gonna
be because I know that's the dirt we all
want to know exactly come on and of
course Prince Harry goes way back this
is a throwback he met them at the London
beer of spice world back in 1997 look at
this look at how cute he was so happy to
be there he's in love I think do you
think he oh my gosh I bet he still has a
crush on one of them you know what I bet
in his heart he's like feeling the
nostalgia of that moment yeah and just
obviously Spice Girls have been so
implementing of the UK and British music
you know it would be an amazing amazing
full-circle moment if they did in fact
perform at the wedding and I'm sure
Megan was a big Sparkle spam there
around the age where they were like at
the peak of Spice Girls like Fanny it
was a global iconic situation and you
know Americans we were just as into it I
love it I love it so yeah that's Harry
when he was a little one and you know
special surprise you guys you know make
it actually has some experience a verse
of her own being a young royal in fact
this is a home video right here you guys
that's the former suit star in nineteen
ninety playing with friends and
pretending to be the queen pretending
she was in fact a royal dad that's
amazing we actually have a little
snippet of you guys watch her just get
into character bossing her friends
around a strong personality but also she
was born to be performer of course she's
a actress and she was like take to
princess I love that binding everything
it's combining the acting the future
royal who knew she manifested it you
guys she was always meant to be a royal
I love that did you play like t and like
Queen when you're a little girl I guess
so I not like that I don't think I did
Dani was also born you know I'm waiting
waiting you know uh that's really cute
so adorable I hope they actually play a
lot more home videos and stuff like that
happens at weddings right totally
slideshows of the bride and groom when
they were little oh I love that so much
let's see happy panda on YouTube as
asking do you think she's going to cry
Oh question I guess I don't know it
depends I think it depends if you're a
crier or not by nature I am not so I did
not cry at my wedding I was emotional
and happy and feeling all the things I
didn't cry but I have a lot of friends
who did cry sure but they cried a lot of
things well it's such an emotional
emotional moment but I will say there's
something about having all those eyes on
you and knowing how crazed Megan is
especially when they did their first
interview after they got engaged I mean
she's so well put together I just don't
see her letting herself get to that part
to that to tattoo that place like doing
a wedding you know I feel like she's
gonna really hold it together I think
you're right I think the tears a lot of
times will come at a more intimate
ceremony of a smaller more
situation but when it's something that
large it feels a little bit less
personal it feels a little bit more
overwhelming a lot a bit more
overwhelming maybe she'll hold her
emotions together exactly yeah I hope
you know I want to see Harry cry Harry
you get the one you cry
tearful girl me too and I can't imagine
what its gonna be like for him seeing
Megan for the first time in that dress I
know we're all excited too including
Madeline from Facebook we can't wait to
see that dress but can you imagine what
that feeling is gonna be like for him
the doors open and this beautiful
beautiful bride is walking towards you
you're about to like become man and wife
I keep telling excited for this wedding
I mean Harry he's always been you know a
second
so will you this is his time to shine
okay this is Harry's big moment I think
people are excited about him too this is
a perfect segue because Patricia on
Facebook is asking what is going on with
her dad so we have learned that Thomas
Markel her father actually will no
longer be attending the wedding he told
TMZ after a scandal broke where he was
basically caught staging paparazzi pics
and selling them he told TMZ that he's
no longer going to be attending the
wedding because he just doesn't want to
embarrass the royal family or his
daughter and of course we had a source
told tell us that originally Thomas was
going to be walking her down the aisle
right they've always kind of had a
strange strained relationship but Megan
really wanted to uphold that tradition
so the jury is now Allen who will
actually walk her down the aisle of
course her mother Dorian is in London
with her that's who I think it's gonna
be I would assume that the mother will
step in
they are definitely closer than Megan
was with her father and she's been in
London helping Megan get prepared and
doing all the mommy daughters that you
do before you get married and a source
did tell us that Megan's mom was going
to be playing a big part in the wedding
so I mean at this point I wonder if that
means she's gonna be walking down now we
don't know yet the story I think that's
super sweet and you know what the way
modern families are happening and all of
that there are no set rules hold for who
has to do what at the wedding I danced
with my mom at my wedding instead of my
dad because that was important to me so
I think more and more
like mom should get a lot of credit at
the wedding absolutely I just I have to
say this I do feel for Megan that you
know the week leading up to her wedding
she has to kind of deal with this you
know to me and now her dad won't be
there anymore you know it's very
unfortunate I feel for her and her dad's
had a health scare as Wow before he also
told TMZ that he actually suffered a
heart attack about six days ago and
checked himself out of the hospital so
he was always planning on being there
but now after this scandal broke it
sounds like he's no longer gonna be
attending so hopefully she'll be
surrounded by enough love there and
won't fill that absence and yeah I'm
sure she has such a great support system
so graceful ready to lift her up and
make it the best day ever
I'm sure it still will be yeah it'll be
as I meant you guys that story's
developing we have a lot more on that
over at ET online.com but that's all the
time we have for today I see that many
of you guys are sending your well wishes
and Congrats to the happy couple
we're excited for them too like I
mention you guys we are gonna be live
every day at 12 p.m. Pacific counting
down to the big day everything you need
to know and of course Lauren is on the
ground bringing all that fun stuff so
Thank You Sophie for joining me thank
you absolutely and thank you guys for
watching and we will see you tomorrow 12
o'clock right here daily Danni live
cheerio today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you